so we want to put our guests to work
Champ Bailey top three top five corner
all-time and I think he's in the top
five discussion I mean I'm not just
gonna go out crazy all the famous three
Hollis hall-of-famer get a man come on
guys you can exaggerate practice against
that actually scared me in practice
there's a lot of good wide receivers in
the league right now I want to know how
you'd cover them
first one Tyree kill so your Tyree kill
step to the line you know me I'm Tyree
killer alright you're Tyree kill okay
really
absolutely both fast remember both fast
I won't do this every play but I gotta
get in your face I gotta let you know
I'm here right I mean that's my bread
and butter
yup and right now I'm not stupid right
it's boy wearing a 42 maybe a 4-1 so I'm
aware of that before I play it so my
idea of playing him from the line of
scrimmage is I got to stay in front of
it right you hear this old cliche get
your hands on them man forget that it's
not about getting your hands on them
it's about staying in front of him right
okay making it hard for him to get there
right that's the easy one that's the one
they want and you're not gonna try to
jam them of course you weren't sure I
thought the hands of crazy the hands of
secondary right so I gotta stay on top
of it he wants to run a 15-yard comeback
curl you can have that yeah I'm gonna
come down I'm a pound you all day all
right I'm going timeout right because I
believe you see the film yeah I think a
lot of corners have thought that what
Tyree kill this year yeah we're talking
about me though I know I'm talking about
you I know this this one I made clear
but if he did open up on you and it
looked even faster than it was on film
are you are you coming out earlier I'm
just saying like I haven't seen anyone
that's are you saying it that if if my
film study didn't show the real speed oh
I didn't get fill it and now I'm and you
got out there and he was even faster
than you thought he was getting and that
happened before DeSean Jackson fast one
of the fastest guys I've seen right
probably fast as I've ever covered right
he he blew past me on the first play and
I'm chasing I'm like oh my god it's got
something I thought I played off him a
little more than I wanted to but at the
same time I still got up in his face
when I had the chance you know it's just
being aware of what the situations are
there's a
how to layer through it yeah I could go
on and on about let's do another one
Antonio Brown right there's part of me
that believes that if you saw Antonio
Brown its lockup status it's I got to
get my hands on a bedtime super physical
am i right you're right
I'm gonna tell you why you're right
because film study tells me this is what
I know because I've played against them
I've seen him throughout the years he
has a hard time with big long corners
right Richard Sherman gives them hell
hell hell so so I'm aware of that and no
one factors this in requires you give
them hell right you know it's hard for
him right and why is it hard for him
because they stay in front of him they
make it heart he can't run around him
right just wiggle and just go the tape
will tell you everything tape doesn't
lie agree what about going toe to toe
with a Julio for that long like is that
physically demanding like are you
exhausted more after that game than
after a game against Antonio Brown you
know a got like that he's bigger so he's
not gonna have the same release but he's
stronger so which your feet really play
a role there because if you're just
standing there with your arms out like
this you know I love Brandon you know I
mean yeah these guys yeah grab you they
want you to grab them but I'll try to
get my hands on them but it's really
more about my positioning you know I
just want to make sure that I have a
strong foundation because they'll throw
you by they'll grab your helmet I mean
it doesn't matter fish sterling I mean
he said the king of that grab you pull
you right and another thing you have to
worry about is blocking you do block the
hair of all the guys right now whether
it's Odell Julio Keenan Allen Antonio
Brown DeAndre Hopkins Irie kill which
one of you go in 60 minutes I could get
anything I could get everything it's
gonna cause me to earn my paycheck the
most well I think Odell is probably the
scariest because his run out to the
catch is superb I mean his first step is
superb yes there's really not a lot of
weaknesses in his game yeah he could
catch everything right you know what's
route running is excellent right you
know so you've been saying this for
years
oh yeah yeah yeah people want to hate on
Odell I get it I mean he's a little
flamboyant he likes the limelight like
to dance you know so what but what does
he do between the line
and it's all that matters right so you
know that's why people love to hate on
tio but tio was one of the best ever
right and you know just you know just
watching his game there's really not a
lot of weaknesses yeah playing a simple
yeah I love the fact that we got to see
how you'd play the guys the other aspect
of defending a wide receiver the
quarterback eyes we've had a few
secondary guys here Landon Collins Jamal
Adams they kind of shared that staring
contest with the quarterback and you're
trying to figure it out is there one
that pops to your head right away of
whether it's a Peyton or a Brady or
somebody that game where they either got
you or you got them really good you know
Philip Rivers probably one of those guys
you always let you know when he got you
you know I hated him for about two years
great guy to death right but he was just
hard to deal with you know because he
would you could tell he studied your
weaknesses because you know he would
find those moments when you just weren't
paying attention and he knew he couldn't
attack me to hold game but he had his
moments when he would just throw it in
there squeeze it in there and God was
accurate
looks like it's floating but it's not I
feel like he would say something to hey
would ya yeah I got you right there or
he you know you come back and you jumped
that one I'll do that again or something
a crazy like that it's like half the
time I don't know what he's saying yeah
but I know he's just talking trash and
just you know he's the competitive dude
yeah and I appreciate it more now than I
did then you played with Deion Sanders
in DC what was that year like with him
like what did you learn from him just
being around him you know it's not just
him it's Darryl Greene time soon so I
had doubt Green my rookie yeah yeah and
then Deon comes in I got okay to Hall of
Famers they're already Hall of Famers at
that point right yes right so I'm
thinking okay you know I got two guys I
could learn from first of all before he
even got there I'm worried if I'm gonna
start but everybody made it clear yeah
you're gonna start of course you're
gonna start I know we're gonna start but
I'm thinking like that these are two
dudes I look up to like how do I start
over them right both of them and their
prime I don't love to see them race all
through you really that'd be a tight
oh I don't know yeah Darrell was a track
guy yeah I was a track Darrell when I
was a jumper and Dionne was a sprinter
as well so that's hard I gotta say I
gotta say Darrell because he at least
1/2 you know fastest man he won see the
fastest man a few times I give him there
okay good night so then what about you
and Dan hey you know maybe we're
neck-and-neck you know I can't give him
anything
Hall of Fame were these stories Simms
has shared a lot from his career
beautiful seven eight years of NFL Glory
the poker games in Denver
we had fun first of all but none of us
like to see champ walk in the room when
we playing poker like we all know him
yeah but champs pockets were deeper than
the rest of us so you know that was the
cheapest guy he might have been the
cheapest he wasn't afraid to throw a
little money around every now and then
too every now yeah and I want to buy him
out of this pot I know he doesn't have a
grams a good but he had we had he had
big big stacks of cash that team with
Denver so who would be in these poker
rooms oh man ham Brandon Marshall Lamont
Jordan $800 in left town the last time
we played really you're that I'm
bringing that up Tony should we go
finally I won $100 one night he oh I
don't have the money on me right now
I'll bring by the check in the next day
or two with the lives like three days
later I never saw it yeah one one last
form because I know we're keeping you
forever
the corners right now in the NFL I think
you got a bit of Mount Rushmore but like
who were the two or three that just jump
out to you right now where you just go
damn that's a special special group oh
man I know there's some good ones I
could go on and on I think one steady
God has been impressive is Patrick
Peterson yeah I mean to make the Pro
Bowl every year you've been in the
league unbelievable
another guy we just talked about Byron
Jones yeah he's starting to stick out a
little more cuz I really focus on guys
who have that tough task of matching up
every week right that is a nightmare you
know and he does it and he's done well
Michael Thomas did
nothing nothing right it's because I do
to the technician yes he is a technician
what are you got going on right now oh
well you know I'm I invested in this
company okay W health and basically they
make these sucks
laso sucks and what they do they mimic
ankle taping now one thing every athlete
hates is taping their ankles yes you
know so worse this is worse these things
feel so good I wear them every day got
them on now I mean and for old guy that
doesn't run around anymore I can only
imagine if I was young and playing what
these would do for me you want to know
more about it lasso gear comm tell you
everything about the sock back by
technology great socks